[Música]
una filtración en redes sociales de
documentos clasificados sobre la guerra
en Ucrania y de varios países aliados de
Estados Unidos tiene justamente a este
país norteamericano muy preocupado por
las repercusiones que esto pueda tener a
escala mundial Qué sabemos hasta ahora
pues se trata de documentos que ni
France 24 ni otros medios de
comunicación han podido confirmar si los
datos filtrados fueron manipulados o
alterados y tampoco se conoce quién
provocó la filtración de estos
documentos estos datos o que emiten
estos documentos Son detalles de planes
militares secretos de Estados Unidos y
la otan en Ucrania por ejemplo también
hablan de la asistencia militar a ese
país es difícil medir o estimar el daño
que esta fuga de información pueda tener
en cuanto a la ofensiva ucraniana sobre
todo en algunas zonas específicas Como
por ejemplo en la ciudad de bahamut
también habla de la presunta presión de
Estados Unidos hacia la República de
Corea conocida como Corea del Sur para
que diera armamento a Ucrania y también
menciona posible casos de espionajes de
Estados Unidos a mandatarios y a cargos
altos en gobiernos de países como Corea
Ucrania e Israel justamente Israel es
uno de los protagonistas de estas
filtraciones los documentos revelan que
el mossad que es la agencia de
inteligencia de Israel habría impulsado
las protestas multitudinarias contra la
reforma judicial que está proponiendo el
Primer Ministro de ese país Benjamín
netanyahu estados unidos no ha dado
explicaciones sobre la veracidad de esta
información e intenta que estos
documentos desaparezcan de las redes
sociales y de los portales de
información alrededor del mundo Ucrania
por su parte ha culpado directamente al
kremlin en Moscú en Rusia desde kiev han
dicho que se trata de una información
ficticia que hace parte también de una
campaña de desinformación por parte de
Rusia
para generar digamos discordia entre
Ucrania y sus países aliados sobre todo
los aliados en el conflicto en la guerra
en el donbad el kremlin ha dicho que los
documentos son bastante interesantes y
que Su contenido no se puede descartar a
primera vista alguien si alguien sale
beneficiado de todo esto pues claramente
Rusia que ha tenido información militar
de primera mano por parte de Estados
Unidos y de Ucrania quedan entonces
Muchas preguntas y pocas respuestas
quién pudo filtrar esta información de
ser confirmada que esta información es
completamente cierta Qué impacto tendrá
esto en el escenario de la guerra en
Ucrania En qué posición queda Estados
Unidos con sus aliados con países como
por ejemplo Israel Ucrania y Corea que
es fundamental en el extremo Oriental
del continente asiático a quienes ha
dejado en evidencia en asuntos muy
importantes porque también mencionan
algunos nombres específicos de
funcionarios de los diferentes gobiernos
de todos estos países que les he
mencionado Y si esta información no
fuera cierta entonces hemos caído
incluyéndonos nosotros los periodistas y
los medios de información en la peor
trampa mediática de la historia reciente
lo vamos a analizar aquí en el debate de
France 24 para conversar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a la doctora aribel
Contreras Suárez ella es analista de
asuntos globales y coordinadora de la
licenciatura de negocios globales de la
universidad iberoamericana Ciudad de
México como siempre es un gusto tenerla
a ella conectada desde la capital de la
República Mexicana y desde la ciudad de
Barcelona en España también se conecta y
se une a este análisis Álex calvo él es
analista de asuntos internacionales y de
seguridad se conecta desde la ciudad de
Barcelona en España nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate ustedes pueden dejar sus
comentarios sus preguntas ya lo saben a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y también estamos en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo no olviden
también y ya para terminar que todos los
contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
pues comienzo este análisis dándole la
bienvenida a aribel en la Ciudad de
México a nivel como siempre Un gusto
conversar con ustedes Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el debate y su
opinión como Punto de partida para este
debate opinión sobre estas filtraciones
en este momento tan particular en el que
está en el mundo donde hay tantas
disputas donde está la Guerra de Ucrania
abierta Qué tan grave pueden ser estas
filtraciones
un gusto como siempre estar aquí contigo
en tu programa Santiago y me parece como
Punto de partida hay que comenzar por un
lado tomando en cuenta todos los temas
de la agenda doméstica de Estados Unidos
a la luz de que prácticamente en un año
será las elecciones presidenciales Y si
ya esta guerra de por sí ha mermado
muchísimo el nivel de aprobación del
presidente estadounidense yo biden donde
se ubica en los niveles más bajos desde
el inicio de su mandato por el otro lado
deja al descubierto de que Estados
Unidos le da el mismo tratamiento en
cuestión de espionaje a un enemigo que a
un Aliado y esto deja muy mal parado en
Estados Unidos a la luz de que estamos
viendo que Europa también Busca este
acercamiento con China para poder
deslindarse un poco de esta gran
dependencia que ahora tienen términos
energéticos con la Unión Americana
que entonces la información que se está
difundiendo y donde inclusive the
Washington post pone sobre la mesa y
puntualiza con nombres apellidos a
países como Egipto donde Afirma de que
un país como este de medio oriente está
en la disposición de proveer armamento a
Rusia Entonces ahora ya nos si ya de por
sí estamos en una guerra mediática al
inicio de esta guerra militar en Ucrania
Ahora nos genera una gran confusión
Santiago de distinguir que es real que
no es real Qué documentos son originales
Cuál es el pentágono se va a deslindar
como información
confidencial y de fidedigna y por lo
tanto ya también hay una gran confusión
a la opinión pública de si lo que se
está publicando los medios
estadounidenses es información real
filtrada o bien ahora Ya se está
inventando Pero lo que sí es un hecho es
que la Casa Blanca pues deja
desmantelado
descubierto a sus socios la manera tan
terrible como los está espiando Santiago
es que ha sido muy difícil aribel para
los medios de comunicación poder
confirmar que esta información sea
verdadera no haya sido manipulada que
tenga toques de verdad y modificados
algunos datos para para beneficiar a una
que otra parte de las que se menciona
allí ningún medio de comunicación lo ha
podido lo ha podido confirmar ni
siquiera con fuentes de Estados Unidos o
fuentes de inteligencia a nivel
internacional y por eso lo mencionaba yo
al inicio del programa podemos estar
ante uno de los engaños mediáticos más
grandes de la historia Mire lo tomamos y
lo coja así con pinzas porque el tema es
muy complicado a nivel mediático le doy
la bienvenida a Alex en la ciudad de
Barcelona Alex Gracias por estar con
nosotros un gusto tenerlo hoy con
nosotros aquí en el programa Y también
su opinión sobre sobre estas
filtraciones en este momento tan
particular y Qué tan grave es esto
pueden llegar a ser a nivel
internacional bienvenido
Muchas gracias En primer lugar por la
oportunidad de tomar parte en este
programa yo aquí quizá optaría por una
postura algo diferente de lo que nos
haya comentado la doctora Contrera es en
el sentido de en primer lugar de que
siendo realistas yo creo que todos los
gobiernos saben que expían y son
espiadas y el hecho de ser Aliado o ser
enemigo o ser algo entremedio Porque
tampoco es que sean dos categorías tan
tan categóricas como nos pueda parecer a
primera vista evidentemente pues puede
ser objeto de polémica de interés
mediático es normal pero para los
gobiernos y Los profesionales que se
mueven en estos ámbitos no es ninguna
sorpresa hablemos de Estados Unidos y
ucraina o hablemos de cualquier otro
cualquier otro
país Alianza sea bilateral o sea
multilateral esto en primer lugar en
segundo lugar en relación al propio
contenido de estos documentos
comparto lo que os haya comentado de que
realmente pues no no sabemos nadie Está
seguro de si son Auténticos de si no de
si son Auténticos Pero quizá Pues algún
detalle o algún algún aspecto ha sido ha
sido manipulado o retocado y tampoco
sabemos exactamente pues Quién ha
procedido a esta a esta filtración y con
qué y con qué objeto Pero
y en esto no es que sea una opinión
original mía ya otros analistas se han
expresado en una línea parecida Yo
estaría de acuerdo con ellos en el
sentido de que no veo que realmente
revelen
ningún secreto ni aporte nada que sea
una enorme sorpresa Más allá
evidentemente del interés que pueda
tener por ejemplo toda la cuestión del
espionaje entre capitales entre
capitales aliadas pero realmente
cuestiones de tipo operativo como la
pregunta que se está haciendo mucha
gente de realmente Pues si habrá o no
habrá una ofensiva de primavera contra
contra las posiciones rusas Cuál será su
eje si se un eje único si será diverso
Hasta qué punto pues estará dictado por
imperativos políticos Hasta qué punto
Pues será más bien una ofensiva diseñada
desde una perspectiva estrictamente
militar
todo esto no parece que estos documentos
lo revelen si lo revelasen el escándalo
y el interés Pues sería un sería un
mucho mayor Claro que haya que haya
conversaciones entre los gobiernos de
los diferentes países o como dice Alex
entre capitales que
queden evidencia en este tipo de
documentos que tal vez Washington ha
presionado a seúl para que le dé a
Ucrania en el marco de esta guerra
también es normal son países aliados son
países que tienen una relación muy
fluida y hablarán de todo tipo de cosas
lo que resulta extraño acá es la forma
como nos hemos enterado de ese diálogo
que es más allá de lo diplomático de las
de las fotos y de las manos estrechadas
entre los funcionarios de los diferentes
gobiernos es la forma como nos hemos
enterado a través de una filtración en
redes sociales no han venido los
gobiernos a decirnos Washington está
presionando un poco a Corea para que
colabore en la guerra en Ucrania que eso
sería un caso diferente Álex continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
y hay un punto importante y es que
algunos de los funcionarios de Estados
Unidos estaban diciendo que había
muchísimos datos
importantes relevantes o no en estos en
estos datos filtrados que pertenecían a
información que solamente la
inteligencia de Estados Unidos ha podido
tener acceso eso los lleva a pensar que
la filtración fue hecha desde Estados
Unidos Aquí tal vez está descartando ya
en este primer escenario que Rusia haya
tenido algo que ver como lo ha dicho
Ucrania que es una campaña mediática o
algún otro agente extranjero qué
intención Podría tener esta filtración a
nivel internacional cuál sería el
objetivo de filtrar esta información que
así como usted dice Puede que no tenga
Mucho peso no son datos relevantes en
algunos casos Pero cuál es la intención
sí es una buena pregunta asumiendo no lo
sabemos pero vamos a asumir Porque
además hay motivos No hay argumentos
para para pensar que es así como se te
ha comentado no que realmente la
filtración provenga
de Estados Unidos y alerta si me
permiten un pequeño inciso no olvidemos
que aunque en relaciones internacionales
hablamos de los estados como un todo
monolítico decimos Washington ha hecho
esto París ha hecho lo otro según ha
dicho esto pero en la práctica en la
realidad pues cada estado está formado
por sus diferentes organismos entidades
personajes y cada uno pues con sus
propios intereses y a veces no siempre
no siempre en la misma línea por tanto
cuando decimos que esto puede venir de
Estados Unidos no quiere decir
necesariamente que todos los actores a
nivel interno norteamericano hayan
participado de esta filtración estén
interesados en dicha filtración o tenga
o vean la misma con el mismo con el
mismo objetivo pero hecho este pequeño
inciso para para situarnes para
situarnos suponiendo que el origen sea
si americano una posibilidad sería
realizar una advertencia una advertencia
a Rusia en el sentido de que hay una
ofensiva inminente aunque como he dicho
los documentos no entran en no entran en
detalles pero sí que entran en lo que
sería pues la preparación de la misma
tanto a nivel logístico como a nivel
político en el sentido una advertencia
en el sentido de
intentar
empujar a Rusia a una negociación antes
de que esta ofensiva se materialice sea
porque realmente quien haya ordenado esa
filtración considere que es realista
plantearse la posibilidad de establecer
una negociación o sea porque aunque
piense que es improbable que
Moscú
la dicha negociación de esta manera no
se pueda decir que no se ha hecho un
esfuerzo diplomático para llegar a una
solución a una solución
pactada de compromiso antes de que sea
por la fuerza de las armas que se acaba
incidiendo Pues el resultado de esta
guerra el análisis de Álex calvo desde
la ciudad de Barcelona él hace hincapié
en una palabra importante asumiendo
estamos haciendo este análisis partiendo
de lo que el escenario internacional nos
da porque justamente hay una
investigación por parte del pentágono
para entender esclarecer de dónde
obtuvieron esta información y por qué la
filtraron y cuál sería la finalidad de
de esta filtración de esta
de esta presentación de estos documentos
a través de las redes sociales a nivel
su opinión sobre el objetivo el fin que
podría tener esta esta filtración
fíjate Santiago que yo no descarto y por
eso en un inicio yo hablaba sobre la
agenda doméstica porque pensando
maquiavélicamente
yo la verdad es de que pongo sobre la
mesa la posibilidad de que si bien es
cierto que Se presume que pudiera ser
esta filtración por los propios miembros
del pentágono no olvidemos que el año
que entra se juega algo muy importante
que es el el republicano le arrebaten la
Casa Blanca a los demócratas y en esta
luz de poderes internas quien saldría
ganando de ventilar esta situación y
dejar mal parado al gobierno de Joe
biden pues serían los republicanos el
equipo de Donald Trump Yo sé que lo que
estoy diciendo tal vez pudiera parecer
exagerado eh Muy este pensando demasiado
mal pero la verdad es de que yo no lo
descarto o sea siempre hay que pensar
Quién ganaría en esto hace ratito tú
destacabas que al final del camino Quien
pudiera obtener un cierto beneficio de
esto también sería Rusia tampoco hay que
descartar la posibilidad de que pudiera
haber sido A lo mejor un un hackeo de
información y hacer una simulación de
hacer pensar que fue la filtración desde
el propio Pentágono pero que a lo mejor
en realidad fue algo desde afuera y me
parece muy pertinente que hablemos de
simulación o o asumiendo en esta palabra
tan atinada de de Alex calvo y que tú
también la retomas porque al final de
eso estamos partiendo pero yo creo que
hoy la conversación debe de ser Quiénes
ganan con esto yo baile no sin embargo
sus oponentes al interior Sí y sus
oponentes hacia el exterior también y en
un escenario en el que todas las fichas
puestas en un tablero cuando se mueve
una y tiene un
digamos en el resto del escenario
internacional aquí es donde entonces hay
que analizar
Quiénes saldrían beneficiados hacia allá
debe de apuntar la brújula sobre el
origen o la causal porque hacer una
jugada por parte del gobierno de Joe en
decir vamos a simular que lo adentramos
y que entonces eso pudiera cambiar la
estrategia de guerra por parte de de
todo el equipo militar de Rusia me
parece a lo mejor un tanto hasta
infantil Entonces yo creo que mucho de
esto es totalmente un componente más
político que en realidad cambiar el
rumbo de algún tipo de estrategia
militar
Maribel entonces partiendo de su
hipótesis de esta idea que usted plantea
Quiénes serían entonces esos
beneficiados Ya habla usted de los
republicanos que entonces entendiendo
así las cosas los republicanos estarían
viendo muy lejana esa casa blanca para
tener que caer en este tipo de
escenarios todo esto partiendo de un
supuesto para poder empezar a hacer un
camino favorable para esas elecciones
que vienen en un par de años quién más
se vería beneficiado
Sí claro bueno de entrada por supuesto
que sabemos que todavía falta un largo
camino por recorrer para las primarias
para ver si en realidad va a ser un
Donald Trump o no pero estamos viendo un
gran rebatingo y un momento histórico
que está viviendo Estados Unidos donde
lo que prevalece son estos
ultranacionalismos exacerbados los
neonacionalismos y donde el mundo está
al revés o sea todo lo que pensábamos y
todo lo que nos habían enseñado las
teorías y los libros hoy ya no aplica a
partir de la pandemia y esta guerra
queda en evidencia que es totalmente
mucho más de estrategia fina que de
tácticas porque también tenemos
información de que así como ha habido
bajas de Soldados del lado de Ucrania lo
hay del lado de Rusia y entonces decimos
y como para qué o por dónde debería de
existir este tipo de filtración no
sabemos en realidad si se trata de una
especie como si fuera de un Wikileaks al
final los beneficiados insisto serían
Pues siempre estos personajes políticos
que se jactan de ser de la clase más
alta de de la política pero en realidad
pues a veces son más delincuentes de
cuello blanco que lo único que lo único
que uno se pudiera imaginar internamente
insisto no hay que descartar
un cierto grupo que maneja realmente los
hilos claro los
republicanos y y más allá afuera me
parece que siempre todo va a apuntar a
Rusia a Corea del Norte y a China
justamente párate Ahí va la pregunta que
le quiero hacer a a Alex hay que
analizar Álex los actores que son
mencionados en estos en estas
filtraciones lo decía yo al inicio del
programa mencionan a Corea un país
estratégicamente cercano a Estados
Unidos en la zona del Pacífico y de Asia
hablando de Israel y menciona un
capítulo muy particular del presente de
Israel y son estas manifestaciones que
se están viviendo y que hemos visto a lo
largo de las últimas semanas justamente
plantean esa posibilidad de que el
mossad sea uno de los que esté
impulsando esas manifestaciones
ciudadanas en contra de esa reforma
judicial que plantea el Primer Ministro
netanyahu y también habla de Ucrania
Obviamente que es un país que está Pues
en juego en el escenario internacional
dice algo estos escenarios porque nos
lleva del este de Europa a medio oriente
y al lejano Oriente es estratégico como
lo ve usted
Sí a ver Esto es un recordatorio Aunque
puede aparecer obvio de cómo está
profundamente conectada la crisis la
guerra en Ucrania con otros conflictos
alrededor del mundo y sobre todo sobre
todo con
los conflictos que tiene China con Casi
casi todos sus vecinos con Rusia de
momento no Pero bueno ya han empezado a
cambiarle el nombre oficial a algunas
ciudades que eran chinas hasta la
Segunda Guerra del opio es una noticia
que ha sido publicada pero tampoco ha
recibido mucha atención Y quizá pues es
una anécdota pero yo por si acaso me lo
he apuntado como una cosa tener en
cuenta no hay algunos analistas hablando
precisamente como la doctora Contreras
hablaba de los republicanos a mí yo
personalmente hablar como decía antes de
los estados en términos tan monolíticos
no me gusta y menos en Casos como
Estados Unidos donde partidos políticos
son
menos bloques que en otros países hay
países donde toda la política se
canaliza a través de determinados
partidos políticos y es muy difícil que
cualquier
político se desvíe de lo que sería la
postura de su de su partido no es el
caso de Estados Unidos en Estados Unidos
Pues los partidos a veces de manera un
poco exagerada se dice que son sobre
todo maquinarias electorales Es cierto
que son algo más pero a veces pues entre
diversos políticos Aunque pertenezcan al
mismo partido las posturas son
radicalmente diferentes y muchas veces
los cambios
en el color de la Casa Blanca no se
traducen en enormes golpes de Timón
entonces concretamente en relación a
China yo sí me permiten voy a centrar
entiendo que lo que usted ha comentado
sobre Israel es importante pero yo
conozco más lo que sería adelante
tranquilo china puede servir para
excelente análisis y ejemplo en esta
situación
a ver quién ha estado precisamente
bastante en los medios de comunicación
esos últimos días a raíz de la visita
oficial del presidente galo al país
también de la presidenta de la de la
comisión Europea y por lo que
precisamente hablaban ustedes en estos
minutos que hemos escuchado antes de
este programa por el viaje de la
presidenta de Taiwán a diversos países
centroamericanos y Estados Unidos y la
represalias en forma de
ejercicios militares que aún está
llevando a cabo a día de hoy las fuerzas
militares chinas entonces hay algunas
voces en Estados Unidos algunas voces
destacadas en el partido republicano
pero no solamente insisto en el partido
republicano hay algunas voces que
están diciendo que Estados Unidos se
equivoca en centrarse tanto en dar apoyo
a Ucrania y se equivoca en centrarse
tanto en oponerse a Rusia porque el
enemigo más peligroso el país más
potente que es competidor y rival de
Estados Unidos es China y que por tanto
hay un claro
coste de oportunidad
Hablando claro pues que cada dólar cada
cada bala que se envía a Ucrania no está
disponible para la defensa del
indopacífico concretamente de Taiwán
pero no solamente de Taiwán de Filipinas
también hay también por ejemplo voces a
nivel menos político más técnico por
ejemplo voces en Filipinas que comentan
hablando de Corea del Sur Como por
ejemplo la filipinas está teniendo
problemas a la hora de comprar
determinados tipos de munición Por qué
Porque aquellos países como Sudáfrica
como Corea del Sur como la República
Checa que tradicionalmente las han
suministrado a las Islas filipinas Pues
ahora mismo la están suministrando a
aura y a Ucrania y como fondo de todo
esto una cuestión que tenemos que tener
en cuenta y es que hemos abusado
nadie está libre de culpa del llamado
dividendo de la Paz es decir muchos
países han optado por beneficiarse de
nivel económico del fin de la Guerra
Fría para reducir al mínimo la
producción militar con lo cual por
ejemplo gran parte del apoyo que está
recibiendo Ucrania viene de stocks de
diferentes países y eso también Explica
en parte esas presiones por ejemplo pues
a Corea del Sur y otros países para que
vayan enviando stocks de de munición
armamento que nos hace servir etcétera
A Ucrania pero evidentemente una guerra
de la intensidad de la que estamos
viendo en Ucrania es una máquina de
consumir es como una hoguera el vas
tirando leña pero no no se acaba hay que
hay que echarle más Más madera por tanto
Es evidente que hace falta una
reindustrialización militar en muchos
países sí se quiere continuar
manteniendo una guerra de intensidad y
desde el punto de vista ruso pasa lo
mismo eso explicaría en parte pues del
interés ruso en obtener el apoyo de el
apoyo de
por tanto preguntarle También usted qué
análisis puede hacer de estos países
estratégicos aliados de Estados Unidos
que mencionan acá a mí me parece que al
azar se están tocando cuatro puntos
geográficos muy importantes dada la
geopolítica y dada las circunstancias a
nivel internacional para allá Es para
donde en ruta la pregunta y también cómo
queda Estados Unidos de confirmarse que
esto es cierto y que no es la primera
vez que espía a sus países aliados cómo
queda Washington frente a seúl frente al
gobierno de Israel y frente al
presidente de lensky en Ucrania donde
Aparentemente queda en evidencia a
través de estas filtraciones algunos
planes estratégicos a nivel militar que
ya ha llevado a que el ejército
ucraniano tenga que movilizarse O
cambiar la estrategia porque eso ya
quedó en manos de los rusos
por supuesto Santiago y estamos viendo
que Estados Unidos no es un Aliado de
confiar y que a la luz de todos los
acontecimientos que ha estado sucediendo
con en Israel con Benjamín intentallajo
ante esta reforma judicial donde Si no
es por la presión de Washington y las
manifestaciones pues no hubiera hecho
esta pausa y si vemos a Corea del Sur
que ha sido muy reservado con respecto a
de que las armas que le ha vendido
Estados Unidos no quiere que caiga
territorio ucraniano y donde vemos
también a a Japón con una política de
neutralidad donde es Aliado de Estados
Unidos pero no se quiere involucrar en
Ucrania entonces queda se sienten ellos
desnudados ante la opinión internacional
donde entonces dice cualquier
conversación que tengamos cualquier
estrategia que implementemos Estados
Unidos no solamente nos está espiando
sino que ahora caemos en Las garras de
quedar al descubierto sobre todos los
movimientos que estamos creando
alrededor grandes aliados
incondicionales los puntos y los países
que tú has mencionado sin olvidar que en
el Indo Pacífico pues está la puesta de
que cuatro países como es Australia
Nueva Zelanda Corea del Sur y Japón se
sumen a la alianza militar conocida como
la otan para que le llamen la otan Plus
entonces no es yo digo que no es
coincidencia estamos hablando de socios
comerciales pero aliados incondicionales
de Estados Unidos donde tiene también
sus propios temas no solo de
confrontación con China y o Rusia sino
de manera indirecta Pues también han
tenido sus propios conflictos a nivel
internacional estamos en una situación
donde la el mundo se está moviendo de
una manera muy rápida donde no todos los
países están alineados al cien por
ciento con Unidos pero tampoco quiere
decir que con china con Rusia y yo creo
que lo que estamos hoy viendo es una
verdadera turbulencia que
sin pensarlo y sin haberlo planeado
desde el kremlin yo creo que Vladimir
Putin está feliz de ver todo lo que ha
estado ocasionando en cuestión de la
turbulencia financiera energética de
seguridad alimentaria hoy hablando de de
este tema y y ahí es donde vemos si en
verdad esto es casualidad que es
coincidencia si es algo planeado y donde
la selección de la información me parece
que no es casual y donde se quiere
generar tsunamis políticos es justamente
en la región indopacífico y en la región
de medio oriente
a nivel es que si esto se llega a
confirmar que tiene
algunas modificaciones la información y
ha sido manipulada alguna forma en esa
compleja guerra que ha sido la guerra en
Ucrania que no solamente allí en el don
vass en las ciudades que se ganan metros
a metro calle esta guerra también ha
estado en el terreno mediático y sin
quererlo en este momento estaríamos
nosotros siendo parte de ese de ese
combate mediático y seríamos
prácticamente nosotros sin querer
queriendo como dice muy popularmente
siendo parte y soldados de esta batalla
mediática debatiendo por unas por una
información que podría haber sido
lanzada al mundo entero simplemente para
tener un objetivo claro y sin sin
confirmar que sea cierto esto Qué
impacto entonces puede generar a nivel
mediático y a nivel de las relaciones de
Estados Unidos
en cuestión de mover y meter turbulencia
a la propaganda es decir aunque todo
esto fuera una utopía Aunque todo eso
fuera falso y aunque ahorita
estuviéramos hablando de algo que a lo
mejor en un par de horas se descubre y y
y ya lo que hablamos Ahorita se
estuviera difuminando al final del
camino sí sirve para seguir construyendo
nuevas narrativas que abonan a la
propaganda al interior de Rusia que
están en calidad de urgencia de seguir
pues teniendo más soldados que inclusive
ya no están dejando salir a a rusos
jóvenes que ya se habían alistado desde
hace meses atrás donde vemos este choque
de narrativas donde también los medios
occidentales se han encargado de abonar
y de construir pero que me parece
importante que aquí en tu espacio en el
debate en francés veinticuatro no
abonamos a esta guerra mediática sino me
parece que estamos abonando al diálogo
construcción justamente al debate para
que ya no nos dejemos engañar y no
caigamos y no seamos presas fáciles de
estas narrativas que tanto un lado como
el otro quieren dividir más al mundo Ahí
es donde yo creo que como sociedad civil
y como medios de comunicación podemos
construir
a ya no abonar más a la polarización no
es que estemos a favor de un país o del
otro y no Santiago tenemos que estar a
favor de la paz a favor de la paz y
toquemos madera que no caigamos en ese
juego mediático por lo menos en este
escenario en el que estamos que es un
tema muy complejo hay mucha información
de por medio que no ha podido ser
corroborada ya me quedan pocos minutos
para finalizar el programa Quiero
preguntarle a Álex esto a dónde nos va a
llevar esto va un poco en línea con el
objetivo que tendría este tipo de
filtraciones Pero qué podemos esperar en
las próximas semanas no tenemos la bola
de cristal siempre lo digo acá en el
programa Pero esto que más consecuencias
puede empezar a traer en el conflicto y
en la relación de Estados Unidos con sus
aliados con los que están mencionados
ahí porque no sabemos si esta fue la
primera entrega y en un par de días
Estamos hablando de más filtraciones
todo puede pasar en este momento
adelante Álex
Sí bueno yo en esto difiero de la
doctora Contreras de entrada esta
expresión de aliados incondicionales yo
creo que no existe no hay ningún país
que sea Aliado incondicional de ningún
otro porque lógicamente pues cada país
defiende defiende sus propios intereses
y hasta los aliados más estrechos de las
últimas décadas como puede ser por
ejemplo Japón y Estados Unidos o Estados
Unidos y el Reino Unido pues tienen
también sus diferencias y a veces
trascienden a la Esfera pública y a
veces no Y a veces pues quedan en la
Esfera privada pero están allí Por tanto
Yo no haría servir esta expresión y
tampoco apelaría a la paz como objetivo
abstracto porque aunque pueda sonar muy
bien
tendríamos que hablar de qué par
hablamos y Es evidente que mucha gente y
muchos países no están dispuestos a
aceptar la paz a cualquier precio de
hecho por esto la Guerra de Ucrania no
ha durado 72 horas como decían muchos
analistas no por qué porque kiev ha
preferido luchar
con el coste humano que ellos supone que
no Rendirse y aceptar la paz porque de
hecho Si se quiere Paz es muy fácil la
paz se obtiene muy rápidamente
rindiéndose ya está te rindes y ya
tienes paz solucionado y de hecho pues
hay en la historia pues ha habido por
desgracia países que han optado por esta
por esta vida Pero hay otros que no
tenemos
Reino Unido y que en el año de 40 Pues
cuando parecía que era de locos decir
que no y resistir pues junto con el
Imperio británico Pues dijo que no por
tanto apelar a la paz como tal es algo
vacío no nos lleva no nos lleva a
ninguna parte entonces volviendo a la
pregunta para finalizar el programa y
tengo que darle la palabra a nivel para
que también concluya muy rápidamente
impacto sobre los aliados cero o casi
cero porque todo el mundo espía todo el
mundo sí Estados Unidos y Israel y
Israel ha espiado a Estados Unidos y hay
gente condenada por Por ese motivo por
tanto son las reglas del juego ya que no
le guste pues que no juega ese juego por
tanto esto no no tiene que ser objeto de
preocupación y sobre las próximas
semanas bueno veremos si realmente se
materializa esta esta ofensiva
básicamente aquí es como en la guerra de
Corea el gran debate se juega a ganar
Álex o se juega a las tablas sí un
minuto a nivel para la conclusión
adelante para el cierre
estamos en una nueva era de esta guerra
Santiago y yo creo que estamos entrando
a lo que ya desde hace meses se veía
venir que son las ciberguerras es decir
más allá de si fue un enemigo extranjero
o o interno esto al final del camino
puede ser el inicio de de Ciber guerras
donde abonan a la infodemia y que al
final del camino pues es todo lo único
que nos genera es a pensar en otro
escenario y una nueva continuidad y un
paralelismo de la guerra en Ucrania a
nivel Alex Muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros haber hecho análisis
de lo que puede suceder con este tema de
estas filtraciones es todo por el día de
hoy Gracias a ustedes por la sintonía En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y Giovanni agudero la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera siga con nosotros siga en France
[Música]